what's going on guys
rogue one hits theaters this week and
it's just me or does it seem like Star
Wars has seeped into every crevice of
the galaxy but believe it or not a long
time ago in a galaxy not that far far
away we lived in a world where Star Wars
was not under a microscope and that
cleared the way for some pretty funny
interviews featuring your favorite
actors that have remained buried in
Internet obscurity but no more get ready
to make the jump to light speed because
screen junkies presents the craziest
Star Wars interviews you've never seen
until now first up let's travel to the
year 1977 and a world that had no clue
what the hell anything in the Star Wars
universe even was a hundred-year-old
wookie whatever that is what a wookies
look like walkies are about seven foot
four they're very hairy everywhere palms
of their hands maybe the inside of their
mouths I don't know Star Wars was such a
massive hit at the time that even its
cast members were caught by surprise
which led to tons of awkward interviews
whether it was respected actor Peter
Cushing trying to figure out who his
character even was wonder what a grand
moff is sounds like something came out
of a clothes closet grandma'll feel it
Harrison Ford trying to seduce this
reporter person are you beginning to see
the effects of Star Wars on your
personal life in your careers maybe
things that haven't been happening up
till now for you well there are a lot
more scripts for me to read and a lot
more people interested in using my
services much to my delight lore Mark
Hamill just trying to explain the plot
it's impossible to really tell the plot
because the plots not that important is
the experience you feel when you watch
it it's when you analyze like I read a
synopsis that came from 20th Century Fox
and I just as a testing out of people's
opinions I would give them the synopsis
and have them read it and they get
halfway down and just say well it's
complete nonsense
one thing's for sure they were already
sick of talking about Star Wars
can you walk down the straightest the
streets in the United States I can if I
want to spend four hours discussing Star
Wars and to tell you the truth I'm sick
of it
fortunately Billy Dee Williams came down
from Cloud City to help do press for the
sequels unfortunately it became
abundantly clear that Billy Dee Williams
didn't know as much about Star Wars as
he does about colt 45 han Solo and
Princess Leia and and the Wookiee and
and c-3po CP oh okay okay
rookie mistake we'll let that one pass
but Billy Dee Williams then had three
years to do his homework before Return
of the Jedi I'm sure things were better
doing the press for that movie right now
those of the Admiral mmm and it was an
earlier Guyana mash those were real
people in math yeah but don't ask me
their names
I think the crazy that I was that's
right next to me my co-pilot is Akbar so
it was it was some yes yeah like that Oh
Billy Dee come on how could you forget
me and nub
that was your co-pilot if he was like
your Chewie luckily this wasn't the
worst performance by a cast member in a
press interview that distinction goes to
mr. David Prowse the man inside the mask
inside the Darth Vader costume watch him
walk right to the edge then tumble off
and then bury himself when he reaches
the bottom in this interview from 1980
the problem was is you obviously realize
I have a west country I was telling that
very very slight very slight and I don't
think they could do Darth Vader with an
English accent that was the big problem
and also you see the character being a
big black character that he is don't do
it
I think George really wanted an obvious
black voice and they've got James Earl
Jones in to do it pull up pull up to me
there is a various a very obvious negro
voice that was not comfortable to listen
to so let's cleanse our palates by
talking about the one thing
Star Wars might be most famous for
merchandising and while it may be a well
oiled precision mechanism now the Star
Wars money machine was sputtering a
little bit at first here's the original
trailer for the first film which isn't
so
much exciting as the opposite of that
[Music]
Star Wars a billion years in the making
and it's coming to your galaxy this
summer geez pick up the pace guys come
on three years later the Empire Strikes
Back released its first trailer made
entirely out of concept art with really
aggressive transitions
Luke Skywalker Princess Leia Han Solo
c-3po r2d2
Chewbacca and introducing Lando
Calrissian can you imagine if the force
awakens' have done that riots in the
streets
they didn't even get Lando's name right
finally the first teaser for Return of
the Jedi got a little closer to modern
trailers but it came out so early the
name of the film wasn't even right
[Music]
revenge of the Jedi
coming next summer to a Theatre in law
galaxy but you can't blame the marketing
team for not getting the trailers right
they were busy slapping the Star Wars
brand on anything with a pulse or a
price tag here are Carrie Fisher and
James Earl Jones struggling their way
through one 800-number promos they
managed to rescue the princess and to
destroy the debt but the Rebel Alliance
must and will succeed and forever riding
the galaxy of their Sochi oh you can
just pick it up no I don't care I'll do
it again
they managed to rescue with the princess
and to destroy them they managed to
rescue the princess hmm but the Rebel
Alliance must and will succeed and
forever ridding the galaxy of their
scoured what the hell is George why do
you give me this ancient dialog to say
tell but it's so rank sure what am I I'm
right here is a Kenner ad that's
literally just for a box to hold your
Star Wars stuff in okay if the Star Wars
mini action figure collectors case
action figure sold separately the
collectors case holds 24th power thank
you baby
oh and folks who wouldn't want this
amazing r2d2 toy it even makes the
world's most annoying sound it's Star
Wars radio-controlled r2
two to nine volt and to see alkaline
batteries not included
you can make r2d2 move beep and flashes
light by wireless radio control
wow what a living nightmare by 1983 Star
Wars was such an obsession that world's
began colliding here's a 1983 making-of
documentary with an interesting host
Return of the Jedi is the third episode
of the middle trilogy in other words
George Lucas sees this epic adventure as
three trilogies three sets of three
films each or nine episodes that will
span 40 years right now we're going to
look at some footage having to do with
designing the new creatures and aliens
from the third episode of the Star Wars
saga come on that's just not right
that's like Superman showing up in a
Marvel movie Star Wars and Star Trek
should never cross streams the world was
going so crazy people were even willing
to pay what was top dollar back in the
day to get to see the movie
the forest is with more than just the
characters in this latest edition of
Star Wars it will be also felt in your
wallets where tickets are going for 450
to $5 $5 for a movie what's next dollar
50 gasps but then no one seems to mind
anyway and finally we move on to what
has become the lifeblood of the modern
Star Wars fan speculating about Star
Wars we live in a world where we can
look forward to watching a new Star Wars
movie every year until the Sun goes
supernova and destroys us all but back
in the late 70s and early 80s the future
of Star Wars was very uncertain here's
the cast getting a lot wrong but a
couple of things very right about the
Star Wars sequels and prequels the
sequel is being written now has nothing
to do with following up this story it's
just a whole different story and it
won't be called Star Wars 2 it'll be
like you know from all the wrong with
love than the alien who loved me
basically this is the second of three
films that tell one story and
originally called The Adventures of Luke
Skywalker and it just was too big to get
on the marquee it just so happens that
the next trilogy after the next film
will go 20 years earlier and tell of the
young Alec Guinness character and how
Darth Vader came to power and then we
wouldn't be involved in those this is
the third is there gonna be another one
what do they what do they say I don't
think so I said can you I mean Han and I
sort of choosing what planet to live on
and having a child that grows up with
hair like that and so what I know I
think they they were considering doing
the prequels one two and three and I I
don't know who they're gonna do that now
so loyal to George and I owe him so much
he at one time said would you consider
playing an obi-wan type character
handing X caliber down to the next
generation I said one that would that be
and at the time he said around all
around 2011 I thought she much as I'd
like to have a job lined up at the turn
of the century I was figuring out how
old I'd be at that point you know it's
good to see Mark Hamill get something so
right after getting things wrong for so
so many years so what'd you think
do you see your favorite Star Wars
actors just a little bit differently are
you excited for when me and screen
junkies dig up awkward rogue one
interviews sometime in the year 2046 let
me know in the comments below we want to
know I want to thank you for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye hey guys did you know that this end
card works with your phone now I know
right click the boxes below to watch
more screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more